مرحبًا ، اسمي باميلا أب كاريون
راسل وأنا ملكة الهالوين
وهي علامتي التجارية المسجلة
وهذه هي قلعة هالوين متحف
مرحبًا بكم في متحف Castle Halloween ، لقد
جاءت هذه المدفأة في الرف
من ملعب جولف مصغر في Windsor
Locks Connecticut لدينا ما يقرب من
35000 عنصر  هنا في المتحف لمدة 48
عامًا من جمع ما إذا كانت
لوحات فخار فنية شعبية روحانية سالم
محاكمات ساحرة
ما هي ساحرة بدون رأسها هذه
غرفة الأزياء هناك أكثر من
ألف أزياء في هذه الغرفة لم
تكن مقاومة للاشتعال ولا تنس هؤلاء
الأشخاص  كنا نستخدم الشموع الحية في هذا
الوقت ، فنحن نغطي أكثر من مائة
عام من الألعاب ولكن بالطبع لديك
لوحة الويجا إذا كنت شخصًا جيدًا ،
فأنت ستجلب الأشياء الجيدة إذا
كنت شخصًا سيئًا
الأشياء التي تجعلك تشعر
بالأشياء ، تذكر موري كانت لتذكر
الموتى لأنها مثيرة للاهتمام لأنها
مصنوعة من شعر بشري كان الأمر أشبه
بامتلاك هذا الشخص  rson هناك معك ، هذه هي
أرواح الأرض التي أحب أن يكون
أحد هؤلاء الرجال على قيد الحياة في فناء منزلي
وأتى للتو إلى هنا وأكون جزءًا
من حياتي ، فقد كان الأمر غير مرغوب فيه بقدر ما
كان الناس قلقين إذا كان هذا هو ما حصلت عليه
حصلت لقب الملكة على Halloween Queen ، تم
إعدادنا في عرض عتيق فخم للغاية ، وكان هذا
الرجل يشعر بامتعاض كبير من عرض الهالوين الكبير الخاص بي
حقًا ، فأنا
لا أريد كل هذه الأشياء غير المرغوب فيها في Halloween Queen
، وأتذكر أنني نظرت إليه وأقول ما إذا كنت
لا تحب  إنها تغادر الآن خاصة بعد صدور
كتبي وبدأ الناس في
رؤية قيمة
وتطور العمل الفني وجمال
العمل الفني ، ثم
بدأ فجأة بالخروج من عيد الهالوين المصنوع من الخشب
الذي لا علاقة له بالدماء
في الحرب.  طريقة إعطائها
تمثل الحصاد وحقيقة
أنك ستنجح خلال الشتاء
إنها قوة الحياة التي يتم الحفاظ عليها دون انقطاع
[موسيقى]
استخدام الحياة الواقعية يمكن أن يكون قاسيًا جدًا
وقبيحًا في عيد الهالوين ، إنها عملية شفاء
تشبه  لديك مرجل كبير من
الماء وتبدأ في وضع كل هذه
التوابل الرائعة سواء كانت Ludo
Flags ، يوم الموتى ، شرق
الساحرات من السويد باترول من النرويج ،
فهي تجمع الأشياء معًا ، فهي لا
تتسامح مع عدم التسامح وهذا ما
يجعل حياتنا  أغنى
hubba-hubba dingle- استرخى
أستطيع أن أرى من كل زاوية كان في
مجلة أو كتاب منذ مائة
ألف عام